we're going camping I documented going
camping before it's tough yeah I'm gonna
show people the natural beauty and then
we'll come back and show how far you've
got going camping and we're gonna
document it unless I forget to document
it which is probably likely and we also
I just remember don't have chairs not
gonna be a fun day
this is what you do if you here's our
campsite we're gonna make it we're gonna
basically do it raccoons do to garbage
turn it out I have to film this just a
queen-sized air mattress it's huge and
the tent that it's supposed to go in is
not huge developing on the outside or
using it as a flotation device in there
the moment of truth stupid against this
beautiful majestic backdrop like an
idiot they're talking about my poor
decision by queen-size air mattress but
jokes they played they played belongs to
I bet camping I'm outside this is what
it is
but at poor Baca and here's my TV for
the night the fishwire has immediately
got in a giant angle this is a new fun
television show that are watching how
did this happen it's a lot you're a full
shot right now the Sun reflecting off of
this bonanza favorite Disney movie
Tangled see how much was lost much line
has been lost with one cast situation ok
my solar-powered lights doing fantastic
worth the purchase what are you doing
having a seance the first
[Music]
we survive without numbers nerdy little
duck creatures are back trying to get
food and then these bitch-ass crows came
back you force them into it or not go as
planned all right well we won't need you
know we got another tangle any signs
I've told us today that we both should
not be fishing that's a great trout
[Music]
there aliens and fish yeah okay so
fishing Sun has settled this camera fell
into the lakes and our following ah yeah
I thought it was inevitable we played
with fire and when you put fire you burn
everything to the ground Sun Goes Down
look who rules the school and ducks are
back and they're going straight for the
fishing line they don't give up to try
and find food
we found a wonderful Italian restaurant
come back to the campsite
what a piece Philippe oh my god look the
fun thing is we're not the craziest
people most normal people this goddamn
Capcom listen quietly
they don't think Charlie Daniels is loud
enough I just heard you cuz voices carry
it's so much oh good learn how it can
we're on a ten-foot air mattress and we
went to a fine-dining Italian restaurant
it feels like it's 3 a.m. you can't see
this but the sky looks amazing I'm
waiting for the moon to go down which by
my Bear Grylls knowledge is in about two
hours great if you hold your fist up
that's about one hour cool look how fun
camping is this is fun but we got some
noisy neighbors and they are no a - of
camping has changed